and i was i was probably making
20 grand in comedy in like 2006.
so i was able to kind of like i did a
couple
like temp jobs but then around 2006
7 i was able to kind of like basically
just be doing comedy
and i was making like 20 like like i
said like 20 grand
and so i remember i just wanted to get
to make
whatever job i would have out like i
didn't go to college so i wasn't ever
going to have some big high paying job
so i was like if i wait tables if i can
make
what i would be making waiting tables in
comedy that's all i needed
so if i could make 30 000 or whatever
i was like then i'll be fine and i'll
that's you know that's what i'd be doing
anyway
i have no education like i'm not gonna
have some big big paying job
so like i would just always try to like
just you have those little goals you
never wanna
get too big on your goals because
they're going to be
pretty tough to reach if you're five
years in and you're like my goal is to
make a million dollars well you could be
you could be one year away you could be
20 years away from that so
you always want to have goals that are
that that can be reached your goals
shouldn't be too high
you know when i was watching bill burr
and when i was starting out
my goal was just to get off that corner
i didn't want to hand out those flyers
i didn't want to stand out in 20 degree
weather and hand out flyers so that was
my only goal
and so i did whatever i had to do to get
off that corner and then i can go
and then go to the next step and then my
next goal was to
like i don't know like to i wanted no
one to ask me to bark because i used to
always get
yeah you can do my show but i need you
to hand out flyers and so i was like i
wanted
to get to the point where they would be
embarrassed to ask me to
to hand out flyers they'd be like well
we can't ask nate so then you just
you're you're then i was just trying to
get to that goal so
when you have those you can be much more
aggressive towards those goals
because they're not as high as you know
they should be your goals will
constantly
change they're always going to change
whatever your dreams are
they it can cha i want to do a sitcom uh
i've tried eight times and have been
told no eight times
and it is what it is man like it's been
the hardest thing to do
uh but it you know whatever man it's
taking
forever and i mean i'm in the circles
doing it we shot a pilot we did
everything
it didn't work out and so you got to
just keep doing it like you're going to
get told no
you know uh mike vecchio who you're
about to interview with my best friends
one of the i say this one of his quotes
all the time which
maybe he's going to say it uh but he was
like
he's like he would always say you got to
get the nose out of the way and i always
loved it
like so you got to get you got to get
told no out of the way
so you're going to get if you try to
like get on a show that you know they're
not going to have you
well you need to go ahead and get told
nobody so go like you know it's like
don't do it too or don't be ridiculous
like you know if you're like i've done
four shows and i'm trying to go do
you know the comedian you should know
show whatever that show in chicago
if it's still there but that was that
show used to be unbelievable but if
you're like an open mic or trying to get
on that show
it's like that's ridiculous but if
you're like i feel like i'm ready it's
like yeah then maybe go ask them
and then you're going to get told no and
get your nose out of the way you got to
get your nose out of the way
great all right well this is um this
could be a no
paul schneider says is nate looking for
a socially distant bff if so i'm willing
to step up
so no that's that's
that's his first note congrats paul
there's two more of those
and then he's gonna be in like you know
the first note is out of the way we're
gonna do one more no and then we'll be
yes awesome so let's just you know
getting it started we're changing lives
here nate
all right the next comes from skip angel
he's out in louisiana he says do you
have a particular writing exercise or
discipline you use often
i so i've i've never written a word for
word i've never i've tried it i've
written it in a notebook
i remember sitting down and making
myself do it i honestly don't i'm
scared every day that i don't know if
i'll ever come up with another joke
uh i've lived in constant fear of that i
have no
system to make myself come up with these
jokes
there's a lot of trust in myself that i
think it's going to happen
i uh i mean you know when i did my when
i did full-time magic on comedy central
i i mean i was like i'll never write
jokes that good ever again
like i'm done and then i did the
stand-ups and i was happy with that and
then after
staying up she like i don't know
whatever i'll do again then you have to
see it
you always you never feel you should
you should never feel like you're you
write a great joke
and you're like i don't know how i'll
ever top that joke you're in constant
fear and panic
that you're never going to come up with
anything i'm scared i have a new hour
and i'm scared after that hour
as i do i can catch myself on stage as
i'm doing this new hour
and i'll be thinking how can i ever come
up with more material
like i'm i think that as i'm telling
these new jokes
because i'm just so i'm like i came up
with these it's going to go away
at some point you know like you're like
i don't i always thought like i wish i
made myself
right in the fact that i wish i had this
system in place
that i could do it now all that being
said
i don't have any messages in place maybe
it doesn't work for you comics are
you know for how hard we work we're also
some of the laziest people
alive and
so but i know that i keep i keep no
a notepad in my uh you know my phone and
i type these notes down
it's a when i do come up with a new joke
i do think of it a lot
and i just you know i can make myself my
brain kind of
get into searching mode like there'd be
times i'll be like
you know at with my new hour i wanted uh
i wanted like maybe one or two more wife
jokes
like i i wanted a couple more wife
things so i was just a little more
conscious i just kind of opened myself
up to like going like all right i need
some wipe stuff and
you just kind of tell your brain that
and you kind of just i don't know then
it makes you more aware
sometimes i'm like i don't want any more
family stuff i want something that's
like not family
and so then i'll just you know you got
to go do stuff that was a big
uh bill birth thing go have experiences
go
do something crazy like you know i'm
writing a joke about chuck e cheese
and i came up with this or this thing
that
was chucky cheese and i've actually gone
with my daughter a few times just trying
to
get material she has fun and then i get
to kind of have the experience so i can
because i want a couple of other things
so
it's it's go have these experiences you
know i know
look seinfeld writes he you know has his
makes himself right every day maybe it's
like go
around look on the internet i've
downloaded little apps i have this
curiosity app
uh that just puts like weird facts out
sometimes i'll go through those
sometimes it's just like getting your
brain like kind of thinking
in a different thing yeah but that's
where you don't go too crazy don't get
on social media too much because then
you end up
you don't want everything to be negative
unless that's your thing unless you're
you know unless you're a comic that
wants to be like that
but you can be very influenced with that
stuff and
then you end up writing a joke that's
like very like limited you know
all this stuff like yelling at everybody